We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two, David P uh,
Gavin McInnes is one of the founders of a,
a an extremist right wing group called the
proud boys.
He has a new program.
That program is advertising on youtube interestingly.
And here's a voicemail.
I got pointing out a very strange double standard.
Take a listen.
Hey Dave, this is Tyler from Alexandria, Virginia.
Call on because I was just watching youtube
and I saw an ad for Gavin McInnes his show
and was just completely shocked that with
all the demonetization going on, that someone
like him is allowed to advertise.
Youtube clearly doesn't care anymore about
what content is accessible to make money off
of.
And, uh, doesn't want to say I've been a member
since 2016.
And uh, anyone who values the work you do
should pitch in any way they can so that you
can completely stop depending on Youtube.
Thanks for the work.
You do have a good one.
Thank you.
And it is stunning, right?
Youtube is really scared about putting ads
on content that is supposedly not brand safe,
including the monetizing a video of mine where
I just played clips from a Donald Trump press
conference.
And meanwhile, the completely not brand safe.
Gavin McInnes who founded an extremist group
named the proud boys, is actually part of
Youtube advertising program and is running
ads on youtube.
It's backwards.
Okay.
And the solution is to separate content and
advertising, make programs that you like independent
of ad revenue, whether it's the David Pakman
show or others.
That's your call to make very, very disturbing
reality is what's going on.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
One of the many member benefits.
Hope to talk the